on a les images
toi c'est un succès gigantesque a quel
âge que tu sors deux albums
ça te tourne la tête si tu viens de
quelle famille modeste comment ça se
fait noir modeste frère
dans la famille
ils ont un peu leur vie elles sont
indépendantes il y a une qui fait qui
peut pas tous en pharmacie ma grande
sœur est née qui est chanteuse
professionnelle donc elles sont déjà
parties elles et quand on vous écoute
tout est il y a bien un moment compliqué
il y avait ça a été compliqué pourquoi
ça a été compliqué parce que je leur ai
pris leur maman quelque part parce que
maman était vachement avec moi au
quotidien j'étais mineur et cetera donc
il fallait qu'elle m'accompagne parce
qu'on était suivi quand même par la date
du spectacle